we have a voicemail number it is two one
nine to david p take a listen to this
voicemail that came in man where is
Trump when you actually need them he got
all the credit for the carrier deal that
he made but my town just lost its
factory trained another air conditioning
company and it just shows you can't just
do things on a case-by-case basis you
need to actually implement reform which
will prevent companies across the
country from doing this you can't just
talk to one like carrier and think it's
all going to be okay absolutely this is
what I've been saying for a while giving
money to carrier is not economic policy
and it's not the free market and it's
not changing the business environment in
the United States very well set on the
bonus show today there's a narrative
spreading that the intelligence
community is getting ready to quote go
nuclear on Donald Trump I will talk
about that i'm also going to talk about
what a city in iowa is doing to help the
bee problem that we have in the united
states and also stories from my recent
visit to the eye doctor some interesting
stuff went on there all of that on the
bonus show david pakman.com slash
membership to sign up coupon code for a
major discount is available david
pakman.com slash membership coupon code
i voted 17